and what will prague
do
we have the first move okay and it's the
queen's pawn opening from prague uh
prague he plays a variety of openings
thanks to ramesh thanks to some of the
other players he works with he's learnt
a whole bunch of openings during the
lockdown over the last couple of years
and it's a queen's gambit queen's gambit
declined which variation are we going to
see is it going to be the semi tarash
this last move but magnus very solid and
uh will he capture with a pawn now in
the center of the board this is so
trendy so fashionable right now
every top ground master playing this
line that means magnus wants to lock
this game down to a draw this is this is
the way to try and draw isn't it now
with black in against well it's one of
the topical lines as you say
everyone's been playing it definitely
um so against one e4 they have the
berlin defense and this is basically the
equivalent
so this is where uh we haven't gone for
the most forcing line where actually
queens often get traded uh prague trying
to keep more tension in the position
which is good i like what prague's doing
but yeah it's uh still been worked out
very deeply this opening it's going to
come down to who understands the
position a bit more
it's actually also a transposition to
the sicilian defense with colours
reversed and my favorite variation the
c3 sicilian yeah it's basically a direct
transposition just white having an extra
move compared to that maybe magnus
showing a bit of respect there because
he's been playing the modern bononi
yesterday he played it in all his games
which is a much riskier opening to play
and this is like one of the most solid
choices he could go for the black pieces
and it's like right okay
you know that is i think a sign of
respect
and actually retreating the queen is
not necessarily the most popular move
and uh well magnus
replied applying by um kicking back the
bishop and uh now the most popular move
according to my database is for the
black queen to take an excursion over to
the left and start attacking the b pawn
meanwhile it does look like magnus is
smiling so uh
well he was at least a moment ago i
don't know whether it's the music choice
whether it's the position whether he
really likes it but either way i agree
with you simon it's definitely a mark of
respect um not fear but respect that
magnus has chosen such a solid line uh
no more kind of wild chaotic openings
provoking his opponent and okay he plays
maybe the most safe choice in this
position just developing black's bishop
giving prague the time to castle and now
both sides have mobilized their minor
pieces it's time for the rooks to join
the game black needs to get his queen
out first to connect the black rooks and
then we've entered the middle game stage
where we will see some maneuvering
and ivanka the move you called there
on the board now often white now
challenges this black queen with white's
own queen uh pragnanda could go and use
his queen step in front of the black
queen trade those off but end games
we've seen one end game so far and that
one went in magnus's favor so i'm not
sure queen trade will be in prague's
plans here
actually the most popular move according
to the database is this isn't the most
trendy well not trendy but
this position hasn't actually been
reached that many times
but the most popular move is actually a
very sneaky pawn move
and
it looks like you know white isn't
actually defending the pawns under
attack but if black were to get greedy
and snap the pawn well there would be
problems ahead yeah problems ahead
javanka and getting greedy here grabbing
this poisoned pawn on the b2 square
would rebound immediately because white
could trap the queen you just have to be
careful right
where you put your damsel where you put
your most valuable piece and this queen
has no escape route it has to give
itself up for just one white rook so a
small trap there in the position uh the
queen should not go and grab this pawn
i'm instead expecting magnus to
centralize his rooks
and
bring both of them towards the center
now
and there we go he starts by mobilizing
his remaining pieces
yeah i mean this is one of those
isolated pawn positions and i mean this
is
a typical structure that you get with
the one idea where white is really
trying to say i have an advantage
against black's pawn in the middle of
the board
that pawn can't be protected by another
black pawn and that's what white is
really you know it's that straggler
we've talked about pawn structures
before and it's derrick derrick no mates
there um but david the deep one simon
david the d pawn but david you have mate
so i can't really say david no mates
that'd just be that would be wrong so uh
and but the the advantage of that from
blackside is it does give black space
advantage um but yeah magnus laughing
again there isn't he i mean uh maybe
he's got your podcast on he's listening
to anisha's uh interview or something
you know and he's just cracking up at it
so potentially so we assume the players
are listening to music but maybe they're
listening to podcasts maybe they're
listening to something else who knows
and uh are you allowed to listen to
podcasts because there's some chess
podcasts out there i don't think that'd
help magnus but i mean it'd be a bit
strange if you could listen to pod yeah
it would be a bit strange right yeah
because it's uh they could be
yeah i like e4 e5
move the knight
i wonder how it works in other esports
as well what they listen to yeah yeah i
guess
sometimes they have to listen to what's
going on in their games in those esports
but
chess it's not clear what helps we're
still learning yeah it's true um yeah i
mean i've
some people say music some people say
actually you it helps if you listen to
binaural beats
there's like certain frequencies that
you can listen to helps your focus helps
your concentration but all very new
stuff and whilst
pragnando's thinking about what to play
well we have some
some selfies that i'd love to share with
you and uh first one is from jonathan
elmore who is watching us from savannah
state university and magnus against
prague feels like a preview of the
future indeed and uh he loves you simon
loves the addition of you
yeah we also like having you in the
studio as well it's a good thing i guess
i'll be in trouble
and jaco ireland is uh watching behind
his desk in oh this is a tricky one cher
panisa sorry if i've kind of massacred
the name in zealand the netherlands
and uh nice to have you watching and
honeybees is also watching from orlando
florida and remember we love seeing your
selfies we love seeing
where you're watching from if your pets
are joining in the action and do we have
any extreme selfies yet this is what
we're looking for yesterday
what's wrong with people just get on
your phone you know while you're driving
your motorbike down the motorway no
don't do that don't do that that was
definitely that would say what you
shouldn't do that's that's what i was
just saying don't do that one but all
your car or anything like that and but
maybe a top of a mountain
would be good
under the water you know anything even
in your bath but make sure you make sure
you get good yeah make sure you don't do
that either
it's such a nice experience
all right what's happening in the game
david quickly please we do have a few
moves
past everyone's bedtime here
and we do have those few moves uh white
pushed upon gaining some space on that
left flank and actually magnus took a
decision i don't really approve of
magnus just pushing one of his his own
black pawns and that has allowed prague
time to centralize one of the white
rooks and i think i've actually reached
this exact position but with colours
reversed and uh that meant uh that was
actually from a sicilian defense that
meant that in that position black had
the extra tempo so i've had this
position but with black to play
basically just with the white pieces a
bit of a
inception there a bit of a mind a bit of
a confusing thing but yeah in chess
sometimes you transpose to different
openings just with colors reversed i
mean if you had to play either side i
mean i guess in the position as kind of
dynamically equal
would you prefer to be white or black
here um traditionally i've always had
these positions or this type of position
from the black side with the isolated
pawn
but uh
it's hard to call i the older i get the
more i enjoy playing against the
isolated pawns so
um how about you simon
i'm i i actually in this position i
think i'd prefer to be white
i mean i like having the isolated pawn
but only when i can
go for a kingside attack um and i don't
generally like playing again with the
isolated pawn because you always have to
worry about things getting exchanged off
in some ugly ending uh that's that's
just there it's just lurking there the
whole time so i'd probably i'd probably
prefer to be white here mm-hmm yeah
yeah me too as well you know like david
the older i get the more i like to have
those positional advantages i don't like
the stress
involved when you you know that if you
trade off pieces
you might be in for a whole lot of
suffering and uh well prague kind of
playing according to the rules you know
he's taking some time out just to give
his king a little bit of space yeah i
think actually that's a very concrete
move it's designed against black
advancing a porn in front of the black
king and magnus suddenly frowning magnus
not liking his position too much i think
and i just smiling five seconds ago and
then suddenly frowning exactly yeah he
doesn't like the music
maybe it's the music but i think it's
also to do with prague's last move it's
a very clever one and uh just to show
why i'm so impressed by the maturity of
the 16 year old with this last move if
he just played the obvious move here and
brought his rook to the side then black
does have ideas for example pushing a
pawn forward hitting white's bishop the
bishop retreats and maybe even pushing
the pawn forward again in some
variations forcing white's knight away
the knight can park itself in the center
there would be some trades there but for
example if it goes away from the centre
of the board then suddenly black breaks
through in the center and isolated pawns
if you can break forward trade things
off you kind of increase the dynamism in
your position look at black's rooks
they're very active as well all of
black's pieces come to life but with
this last move prague he's thinking
about the opponent's plan pushing his
pawn forward now this doesn't work at
all for black this is only weakening the
black king because suddenly this pawn
push is just met by a capture
so prag just looking into the future
thinking about what magnus wants and he
stopped it and i really love this move
also the white king now with some
breathing space great move but there by
prague
and magnus he has gone into a little bit
of a pause we did see a smile on
magnus's face in this game now svadam
what would you say is the mood both for
the world champion and all the players
today so far i'm actually fascinated on
the side here because i'm watching i'm
watching trent on the side trying to put
up the position on the board that's here
and he's trying to give johan sebastian
next to me his opinions on things and
what are you thinking right now
this position is a reversed
alapin a reversed c3 sicilian and this
is a a line i used to play all the time
as a kid and jan sebastian was like no
it's not and i was like you just did a
course on the elephant didn't you this
is like your opening
uh but i think it is if i i mean we
could get the same position very similar
with the with colors reversed um
which if that means it's probably very
decent for white you would expect with
an extra move basically
so
yeah i know that's a bit technical but
yeah that's lauren's take what's your
take on mainz's position is he in solid
shape i think his position is pretty
solid but as lauren says it's slightly
better for pragnanda and he's not really
risking too much
uh you're also following
jordan's game pretty closely here but
that's been quite explosive so far
hasn't it yeah well we we were actually
a bit inspired by lawrence uh publishing
his uh course on the move one night c3
today so we discussed it for like five
ten minutes that's accessible right
that's uncheckable yes very good course
people should check it out
and we just thought okay let's have fun
play it it's a very aggressive move and
it got a very interesting position
very original position which i've never
seen something like this and it's even
hard to say who's better but it's a lot
of things happening so it can go either
way that's just our take just just a
little hint of a secondary game that you
may keep an extra eye on but for now
it's interesting to see if mundus can
hold this
definitely thank you sweater and uh yeah
let's just uh take a peek at uh the
second game between yord and phan for
east and anish geary a second johan
sebastian revealing that there's been
some preparation for this game
with uh the c3 opening wow knight to c3
that's right and uh i don't know what i
don't know what lawrence has paid jordan
to play that move or one night c3 but
it's a great advert for lawrence's
course and he's got a great position as
well jordan you see the body language
there jordan and anish both focused it's
really dynamic really uh really tense
battle there you can see the evaluation
bar and their match down at the bottom
there roughly balanced but
yeah yeah it shows there is room for
creativity in the opening whenever
lawrence comes out of the course it does
take the chest well by storm
you know one knight c3 his chest ball
course is out today and uh today today
yeah and if you want if you want kind of
a maverick opening to play is you know
he is a great he knows his stuff
incredibly well so it's well worth
checking out um but yeah it's quite
funny to see he brings the course out
and all the top players it's another
laurence trent course
we've got to play that move so uh yeah
interesting and we also have the simon
williams chessable course on how to play
like tall basically yeah it's it's the
life and times of mikael tao um so it's
a famous book written by him uh very
funny book actually it's all about his
thoughts and i've tried to bring his
funny guy he was a funny guy yeah he was
he was a really unique character he's
like yeah one-of-a-kind kind of guy and
uh very very brilliant book and i've
just bought try to bring some of the
games into videos so i've done the
videos for that and there's 15 hours of
me chatting about his uh his play so
yeah very enjoyable that would be very
entertaining can't wait to see it
absolutely and meanwhile white has moved
the rook and aligned it to look at the
black queen and
whilst magnus ponders over what to do
next well gives me excellent opportunity
to share with you some more selfies we
do love getting them and brian h live is
watching magnus carlsen with none other
than the future queen of chess adeline
rose one years old that's very very cute
and looky here someone is playing hooky
from work
to catch great chess instead take a look
at that
sarah and eric
getting in on the action uh love that
love it indeed how cool is that during
the chess tournament swat is able to
take a selfie with one of the great
players i know very cool and uh magnus
moves his queen and uh mecha d hassan is
actually doing science whilst watching
thrilling chess i do quite like the
multitasking
tweets and uh if you two want to share
with us your selfies and also get in on
simon's challenge of extreme selfie with
watching the show like where are you you
know the most extreme place that you can
watch the show from then uh tweet us
using the hashtag chesschamps and we
will feature them it will make simon
very very happy yeah we haven't had any
extreme selfies yet i'm you know i hope
no one gets in trouble doing this
sorry people are very safe they're very
safe yeah
yeah which is good which is good stay
safe obviously yeah you know but yeah
well you know
kind of stay safe yeah we still want to
see it on a mountain or something i
think so yeah
all right well on this game david are
the king safe are the queen safe what's
happening everything's pretty safe right
now
and that's good for magnus carlson maybe
the only thing that isn't safe is the
clock time for him uh eight and a half
minutes against pregnant 11 and a half
minutes but uh yeah it's up to pragnando
now to make things unsafe to maybe start
taking some creative decisions start
kind of increasing the pace changing the
pace at least
first i'm expecting white to get a bit
more organized there are some threats
brewing against the white queen
potentially the black light squared
bishop might step forward to attack her
um so i'm expecting the white queen to
maybe take a step back in one direction
there are several options for prague but
uh good opening foundation i'm inclined
to agree with johann sebastian
christensen who we had to chat with
there in the lounge i think white does
have a small advantage but to press that
further is the difficult part
so everything very safe and solid but
prague needs to win
and that's why he's focusing so hard
right now just looking away from the
board there maybe trying to come up with
some creativity and then looking back i
have a question for you david because i
suddenly just dawned on me the queen and
the bishop there are aligned to look at
the h3 pawn
danger any danger at all
no not yet as you mentioned ivanka this
is quite a common motif uh a common kind
of pattern that you have to look out for
a bishop and a queen lining up against a
pawn so for example the move or one of
the moves i was looking at dropping the
queen back this could be the trigger for
an attack by black sacrificing a piece
and as you mentioned this could be very
very effective in some scenarios but
here i think white just has too many
defenders the knight is a great defender
most of all the bishop defender so for
example the bishop might step back and
next move the white bishop will evict
the black queen
so uh yeah it looks scary if black gets
maybe another knight or another bishop
into the attack one or two more moves
then definitely something to consider
but
not right now unfortunately i dream for
the time being got to watch out for it
though uh it's always the kind of move
that you know you need to keep an eye on
um i think you need to show patience in
this position in general um because as
soon as someone strikes it it could well
be premature and the position could go
wrong so i think it's just as you say
david prague trying to work out where
his queen is best placed where his
pieces are best placed and keep that
pressure up against black's weak pawn uh
in the middle of the board uh i mean i i
like i like the position he's got i
think this is you know got an advantage
with the white pieces that's all you can
ask for when you're playing the world
champion and as you say he really needs
to win this game so he needs to keep the
pressure on so but at the moment he's
done everything that he's needed to do
and just to explain the reason i like
this move dropping the queen back it
looks a bit mysterious but that's
because i want to support this pawn
pushing forward maybe the queen a decent
square here also i want to bring
the knight to the edge of the board and
the knight can't go to the edge of the
board now because it's actually on a
loose square and this would actually
lose a point after nate takes pawn
attacking the white queen black's queen
could pounce so i want to prepare all of
these ideas but prague he's burning a
lot of time four minutes now and uh he
needs to prepare all of these ideas
maybe take a time out or two he needs to
stay flexible but it looks like he's
looking for something right now
this is not the type of position to
spend
a third of your time on
he spent four minutes out of 12 that he
had and okay he actually plays the move
that i was recommending
um the reason i recommend this is
because it's very typical from the
position with colors reversed that
lawrence was mentioning there and uh
black does the same the queens were
really uncomfortable because the rooks
are also on the same lines as them so
both queens now have kind of run away
to safe squares and it might be time for
those types of ideas from prague push a
pawn forward bring a knight forward
and uh he needs to play quickly
energetically right now
still very tense in the balance despite
the evaluation by liking white
he needs something
right now
interesting pragnanda he only has two
games with the white pieces this is one
of them and he has to make a comeback
after losing the first game in the
tournament for him the first game today
against magnus and if magnus wins today
match then these two will actually be
in a shared lead both of them with nine
points and that's going to give us
a very
intriguing end to the tournament
there is a total of seven days seven
rounds it's a round robin so all play
all in these matches with four rapping
games in each match
pragnanda currently in seoul lead but
magnus is chasing him from behind that's
actually a good point kaia imagine if
prague somehow wins one of the next few
games imagine if it's 2-2 if it goes to
playoff uh prague still gets one point
from that so he'll still have a big lead
over magnus sure or decently going ahead
of magnus going into the last few games
so
yeah i think magnus needs to win this
one in the rapid section uh just to
catch prague and uh otherwise prague
will be the big favorite for the rest of
the tournament oh wow am i i mean
he we talked about him as an outsider we
were so excited to have him here but
actually as a winner of the tournament
that that didn't seem very realistic
right or did it you did mention him i
did mention him in the beginning but
more in hope than expectation i mean
winning this tournament would send
shockwaves around the world uh prague
come we'd probably get another tweet
from the indian prime minister there
because it would be that big an
achievement but uh okay long way to go
don't want to put too much pressure on
him but the way he's played so far
prague
wouldn't be that much of a surprise
anymore
do you guys remember sort of the first
time magnus sent shockwaves in in the
chess world how old was he did he win
something win a tournament he did play a
game against kasparov right yeah there's
this one tournament uh was it in
reykjavik in 2004 i think he was 13
years old i played him there actually so
oh really yeah i played him only in the
blitz but um i played him in reykjavik
and um he he was yeah obviously very
small and um he was just this young kid
who was playing fantastic chess he
didn't i don't think he won the
tournament um i think it might be in
that year very close to there but i
played i played him in the blitz
tournament afterwards and he took my
king in a blitz tournament i was
actually winning and um we got down to a
time scramble and he captured my king so
even though he's a real talent he
clearly didn't know the rules
he can't take the kid take the king
did you say that well actually he won
the game because i didn't i didn't
really know what was going on i mean
have you taken my king what's going on
uh but actually i could have claimed the
win because it's an illegal move to take
the king but in a blitz game it's very
hectic and frantic so you don't know
what's happening wait so why did he do
it because he was just confused well i
put my king in check which probably uh
wasn't a very good idea it sounds like
we're both complete beginners doesn't it
i put my king in chair magnus took my
king i didn't know what was going on and
he won i mean like but it was you know
in blitzchess everything is so quick and
fast it's really really confusing and
hard to know what's going on but i mean
that's that's when i sort of noticed him
but
he was he was very talented it was
something innate uh that made him so
great as well as his hard work as well
and there was the mozart of chess
comments uh that was that tartar steel
um that was yeah i think he won a game
against sipka ernst um dutch grandmaster
and it was an incredible game and that's
when the kind of nicknames the kind of
labels started coming but he was already
a grandmaster then
at a young age and a similar trajectory
to prague actually got 2600 very quickly
and then just kind of took it by storm
yeah he never really plateaued magnus a
lot of players they get good and then
they stop but not for magnuson clearly
not for prague and i really like humans
sorry cinderella i mean i really like
the way this is going for prank i mean
he's made some space look at that night
he's got in the middle
yeah and this white knight that has just
moved it's the ideal piece the reason
you like it so much simon is because if
your opponent has an isolated pawn
knights are the best blockaders if you
plant your knight in front of your
opponent's isolated pawns they can never
ever be moved so yeah yeah white with
the best pieces right now slightly
superior pawn structure still some work
to be done because white's pawns on the
left side of the board now slightly
loose they're very far advanced but they
could become targets uh black star score
bishop may be having some inroads into
that side of the board so you have to
still be careful but
definitely turning in prague's favor at
the moment yeah looks like that and
i'm going to take this
brief pause just to kind of say simon
you set a challenge you know could
people take selfies in exotic locations
our twitter audience says most certainly
they are up for it and tt african vibes
is watching by the fireside at uh in
paris south africa
that's quite cool awesome milan wreckage
actually says challenge accepted simon
ironing while watching chess
extreme ironing have you ever heard of
that they go on to mountains and stuff
so yeah okay yeah also wasn't quite what
i was thinking but you know and samuel
mendes says that this one's for you
ginger gm it's not a bathtub but i think
it will work he's actually in the it
looks like the arizona mountains wow
that's incredible yeah that's a cool
place yeah yeah that is very cool so in
the wilderness
keep those selfies coming absolutely
and keep those moves coming what's
happening on the board david yeah keep
those moves coming indeed prague is
trying to up the pressure he's putting a
lot of um oh he's actually creating a
threat right now if you look at black
light square bishop it's under fire from
white's bishop that's just moved and
white tonight in the center of the board
oh prague really he's trying to move
into the kill he's slowly gravitating
the play towards the black king
for example if we see a capture of this
white bishop that's just moved white's
knight will replace it and we know about
knights on f5 they do thrive so i'm
looking very good for pride right now
i think magnus needs to be very accurate
just to hold the balance i'm expecting
i don't think a trade is really possible
here you can't let white's knight
anywhere near your king so i'm expecting
maybe uh magnus to just defend that
bishop with his queen
the only downside is i was thinking
david something you mentioned that white
has advanced his pawns on the surface i
thought oh that really does that looks
good for white but it's really worth
remembering that when you make porn
moves you can't move them backwards and
uh that might sound obvious but you
create a lot of weaknesses in your
position and there's a couple of squares
now on white's queen side that
incredibly weak that can never be
covered and david pointing out there
that black knight has a beautiful square
it can just sit on and it can never be
kicked away by a white pawn because
they've gone too far up the board so
this is i think what prague's doing it
does make sense but it will give magnus
counter play on the queen side here so
it could be a race
prague going for black's king and then
magnus trying to find some weaknesses on
the queen side so very excitingly set up
at the moment yeah i agree with you
there simon i mean we're going to see a
tremendous battle actually between those
long-term advantages that magnus has and
the dynamic possibility especially the
kingside attack that you referenced
because jumping over the knight looks
good but also comes with certain
consequences too
yeah so right now magnus he's the one
facing the first real threat of the game
he has to do something about black's
light squad bishop
i don't think he should move it or trade
it off oh okay he does move it he does
retreat it
uh oh somehow it feels like that's a
step in the wrong direction to me i
thought maybe he would protect it with
the black queen yeah look at the bar
yeah i mean i completely understand why
he did this it looks like he's keeping
the bishop nice and safe on a protected
square that bishop's actually protected
four times right now
but it doesn't stop white's plan of
maybe trading off those bishops and
replacing white's light-squared bishop
with a knight on that same square the f5
square could be the key launch pad for a
big attack
it's actually possible to for white to
try to get greedy you know and play on
both sides of the board step back with
the knight
and start attacking
a pawn at the edge of the board it
doesn't look like the most attractive oh
we see a trade yeah and this is the move
i was expecting because now white's
knight can occupy that dream f5 square
so uh is he going to do it now if you
don't you might miss your opportunity
right yeah yeah go forward irresistible
that way and if you can get the other
night around i mean that might mean
giving up your queen side but i'd love
to play the move you recommended there
david but then
get all your pieces towards black's king
i mean it's one-way traffic you got to
go for the win just get all those minor
pieces meaning the knights and the
bishops just heading towards black's
king because black has moved a pawn in
front of his king which again we've
noticed these small moves but we might
be able to highlight that pawn and it's
kind of like a hook and you see it is on
f5 and that is now hitting that hook as
well which you might be able to at some
point start to sacrifice on so
aggressive play from prague very
aggressive it's all about this knight
right now putting pressure on this
bishop if this bishop ever moves then
suddenly the white bishop can capture
the black knight safely and completely
wreck the black pawn structure um a lot
of pressure right now it's all about
this knight putting pressure on the
bishop as simon says maybe sacrificing
itself on the square to open up the
black king maybe even sacrificing itself
on this square and uh the key is whether
you can bring this knight into the
attack as simon also mentioned that uh
maybe bringing it back this way uh
towards the black king it takes a while
also a big weakness still in the middle
of the board this isolated pawn
magnus though to be fair to him does
have chances it's against these weak
white pawns later in the game and maybe
he'll try and stack up the two black
rooks to create some counter threats
along this line first he retreats his
bishop i mentioned that retreating the
other way was bad but at least here he
still defends his knight so it's holding
together for now for magnus but it's all
about this night it looks very very
scary and uh this knight could be the
key piece in this attack okay
pragnanda is uh thinking let's uh just
check in with the other matches going on
as well because look at the bar in the
game between liam le and eric hansen
it's shot up for liam le the first game
ended in a draw but maybe liam lee is
about to take the first point in that
match-up eric hanson's struggling he did
win his match yesterday so he is feeling
confident but maybe in trouble right now
in mamadiarov against duda duda won the
first game he's in the lead the bar
slightly in the middle in the second
game against mohammed yarov and then the
all dutch encounter jordan pham for east
with a
c3 opening against aneesh geary the bar
is swinging from side to side so it's
going to be interesting to see what
happens in that one
and then we do have another move in the
big one and simon you must be loving
this last night it's the first race i've
thought of yeah i mean i want to get all
my pieces towards black's king i love
the the swinger the swinging rook um
which we talked about a lot happy in the
past um but but it does have downsides
uh as well david yeah this rook move
looks really nice really pretty planting
the rook on an outpost and trying to as
you mentioned simon swing it across to
the black king
we call this a rook lift you lift it up
the board and then you lift it across
towards your
targets here the target is the black
king but it's not easy to bring this
rook across yet any square this white
rook wants to use is actually covered by
black's knight that black knight is a
great defender
and the downsides you mentioned there
simon you do lose a bit of coordination
suddenly white is focusing all his
attention over on this king's side but
he's kind of neglecting the other half
of the board it's a bit loose especially
white's knight on this left half now
it does feel like
i don't know he's losing a bit of
control he's going for the attack but
sacrificing some stuff it's kind of all
in isn't it this move because you're
you're giving up your hopes on the other
side of board so you've got to you've
got to really go for it now uh is that
overnight if you can get that overnight
and just plonk it to attack the black
queen fantastic but you can't i mean
magnus has this counter play on the
queen side i mean i i still think it's a
fascinating position i know the bar is
saying what 0.0 i mean
it's uh it's certainly not a draw and he
any he's going for it i mean this is
this is really brave stuff
this you need to be brave you need
courage uh that's the only way you'll
get rewarded against magnus carlsen
it might not be objectively correct we
see the evaluation bar now going in
black side white's attack might not work
but magnus the only achilles heel he has
is sometimes he neglects his king safety
sometimes he has been checkmated in the
tour by danny of dubois wesley so a
couple of others
you can't really outplay him in many end
games it's not possible there so you
have to go for the attack so i in a way
i like prague's philosophy behind what
he's doing but it does feel loose and
magnus is about to stack up his two
rooks as mentioned on the c file to
attack white's knight over there and uh
there we go he's played at two black
rooks creating big big threats now they
look good and uh remember this is the
big one today the match up on the podium
but if you are following us on twitch
you can use the command center to have
all the games or as many games as you
want
and follow all of the chess moves if you
want to so chess 24 on twitch if you
want to use the command center wow bunch
of moves yeah bunch of moves and a rook
trade i think that's good for prague's
short term because he's released some of
the pressure the two black ropes were
just too strong but long term if white's
attack doesn't work then white is just
saddled with weaknesses uh the simon
mentioned earlier especially that black
knight on the b6 square
it might be ready to grab a pawn later
on
or at least jump into the right position
and uh
what do you think of this transition
this exchange i really don't like what
prague has done uh i know i admire the
spirit behind it but to me it looks a
little bit clunky and a little bit kind
of one-sided superficial maybe yeah i
mean now i'm just looking at this
position and i'm thinking the white rook
can actually maybe even be caught out
you know be stuck there on this awkward
looking square
and
black's work and night are such
effective pieces i love magnus's
position yeah it's it's incredible i
mean it feels like white's been
generating some threats some attacks but
magnus just stone cold
no nerves just making really nice
defensive moves i mean saying that the
night the night that's just highlighted
a move uh moved if you can move that
okay this is why magnus had to play uh
something that ivanka just mentioned and
go for the offensive because that white
knight is two squares from an ideal
situation i mean i i'm i'm a bit more
optimistic about what prague's done i'm
always optimistic when i see a king and
people start attacking the king but i
think this is a great way to try take
down the world champion um you've got to
take some risks and you've got to go for
it so i you know it does look a bit
strange but
white's pieces are are quite scary as
well oh wait one second isn't there okay
night takes rook yeah i was expecting
the white rook
there's a big threat rook takes knight
oh look at the bar oh no is it a blunder
by prague look at him it's a big blunder
by prague unfortunately and he's just
missed that black can actually sacrifice
a queen on the next turn he thought that
the white knight could come and check
the black king but it doesn't work and
we'll have to show that in a moment but
prague first of all is heartbreak for
him big big blunder there he actually
had a very good move the white rook
could have just moved out of the attack
moved out of the threat and the game
goes on uh prague would have had decent
chances but magnus there he knows he's
winning now the white knight forced to
retreat to attack black's queen but
that's not what prague wanted head in
his hands
he's just lost a rook for only one piece
uh
material advantage now decisive in
black's favor
and uh just while we keep an eye on
prague we have to show what just
happened
it was a huge mistake here the black
knight attacking the white rook and he
just should have moved it he should have
moved his rook to the side lined it up
with the black king and he's fine the
game continues but instead bishop takes
bishop
he had forgotten that after knight takes
rook he couldn't give a check with the
white knight it looks like white is
winning but suddenly black can actually
strike back queen takes knight
sacrificing the black queen and after
white takes white is a whole queen up
for just a rook but this is the killer
blow rook takes knight check this is why
we always go from gotta look for checks
this check lures the white queen onto a
bad square and suddenly another check a
knight fork and at the very end after
the white king moves black emerges with
an extra piece two knights beat one
bishop easily so that's what prague
missed
and uh right now he's stuck in a
difficult situation
material down and struggling
let's go back to the players it's uh
yeah desperate times maybe some some
trick still okay so he's not
like 100 losing
99.99999
it's going to be fine
just be realistic
yeah i see a few very strong moves for
black here yeah i mean you can you can
trade yeah just move the queen two
square forwards
try to get the queens off and then
whites knight i mean you're threatening
checkmate with that move as well um i i
you know magnus has really shown his
class isn't he i mean uh you know kind
of expected he might be today um but
hopefully the big occasions he he plays
well on the big occasions that's why
he's the boss yeah that experience i
mean you don't
win five world championship matches
without uh having nerves of steel
and uh simon's move there offering a
queen trade and also threatening
checkmate the queens have to come off
the board and uh here we go it's
actually still a rook for a bishop
advantage for black but more importantly
white's pieces were attacked and there
we go just a trade of knights there and
when the black knight moves out of the
way it's just an end game
where black has extra material and a
matter of technique as we call it uh the
black knight retreating out of the
threat attacking white's bishop and now
the black rook is going to go and grab
some pawns
the white bishop not able to fight
against blackstroke yeah and somehow you
know it was a very unfortunate mistake
from pragnanda you know when he
blundered
everything fell and all his pieces were
on the wrong squares
so unfortunate sometimes you blunder and
you get a bit lucky you can still fight
and it's still really complicated but at
the very end as you mentioned uh this
queen trade making it really simple for
magnus
yeah and pregnant he realized
immediately we saw on his camera as soon
as magnus replied
he just let back in his chair he
that's how it works in a way isn't it i
mean often when you blunder it's when
you let go of the mouse or you let go of
the piece you suddenly realize
immediately what you've done and it's
very strange how quickly you can realize
it's a serious blunder when you do it i
think i
you know don't know why that is always
but and it's so strange you know when
you're like well brain if you if you
could work one second later why could
you not exactly why now yeah you know
you let me down again
so but this this is yeah this is pretty
the rook is so strong here um you know
it's it's a rook in an ending incredibly
good piece and it can start picking off
the white pawns so it it's yeah there's
not much that can be done here yeah
magnus there he clicked on one pawn he
changed his mind he clicked on another
porn he changed his mind but he does
have many very strong moves here for
black that is the reason and uh we
should mention we have seen prague turn
things around already in his three match
wins uh in previous days he was losing
games in all of those three days
but he managed to win them in the end uh
the problem is this is not that type of
position where you can confuse your
opponent really yeah he's dependent on a
mouse slip or blunder really from magnus
carlsen and less than a minute on the
clock now for pragnanda if he loses this
game then magnus will only need a draw
in game three with the white pieces to
take the win in the match
it's getting quite dramatic now for
prague
and i think we're going to see a result
any moment this last move is really nice
look at the white bishop it lacks escape
squares black has a huge threat of just
retreating the black group up to the top
of the board and white's bishop is
caught
in behind enemy lines if you're if your
phone goes off do you still lose
in the esports arena because obviously
if you're playing chess over the board
and your phone goes off
do you immediately lose okay the game's
over yeah
it's uh
over magnus carlsen winning game two as
well he is up by two points